every image you've seen of a black hole
including this one is a fantasy a
genuine picture of a black hole doesn't
exist but soon that's going to change
why holes in their own don't look like
very much they don't reflect light
because any light that falls into them
can never escape and they don't emit any
light that we can detect those aren't
the only reasons black holes are hard to
photograph even though they're really
really massive that can be millions or
billions of times the mass of the Sun
they don't take up that much space on
the sky they've compressed all that mass
into a really tiny little space the
closest big black hole to earth is at
the centre of the Milky Way which is
26,000 light-years away from us and so
in order to be able to see something of
that size we need a telescope that has a
resolution that is powerful enough that
it could see doughnut on the surface of
the Moon the black hole illustrations
were all familiar with aren't complete
lies plenty of data suggests that black
holes exist some even shoot jets into
space that we can see and spaghettify
stars that get too close
the best evidence for these behemoths is
their entourage they wrap huge amounts
of gas and like charged plasma around
them and as that stuff is trying to fall
into the black hole can't all go in at
once
so it orbits super super super fast and
the friction in that fast orbit and
keeps it white-hot most illustrations
focus on the accretion disk but
we could be looking at the real deal
thanks to the event horizon telescope or
the EHT the EHT is trying to take the
first picture of the black hole at the
center of the Milky Way
it's called Sagittarius a star or sad J
star for short and the team expects to
produce results later this year when
it's actually doing is taking a picture
of the shadow of a black hole on the
stuff behind it by stuff she means the
glowing gas and plasma in the accretion
disk the black hole shadow should create
a silhouette on the disk that outlines
the point of no-return the event horizon
taking such a picture would require a
really really big telescope the HT uses
a lot of smaller radio telescopes
instead they work together using a
technique called very long baseline
interferometry and what that does is it
makes those telescopes kind of act like
one giant telescope scientists analyzing
the data can see how the light waves
detected by each telescope line up with
each other to figure out what's light
from the edge of the black hole and
what's noise the EH T's picture will
most likely look like a rig created by
the black hole's event horizon blocking
out light from behind that first image
though perhaps grainy will give us an up
close look at the accretion disk plus
two key bits of information the size and
shape of the black hole's shadow
and then that will be enough to answer a
lot of interesting Astrophysical
questions about how life was work how
event horizons work what is going on
there the big unanswered questions
include how exactly do accretion discs
form and feed black holes where do black
hole jets originate and the oldy but
always a goodie was Einstein right his
general theory of relativity predicted
that event horizons could conceal tiny
massive objects like black holes the
shape of this image that we see is
something that you can predict using
general relativity if the shape of the
image of the black hole looks different
than we expect that would mean that
something's wrong that we don't fully
understand about general relativity
taking a picture of a black hole will
mark the most extreme test of general
relativity yet this test of relativity
also has implications for the physics
theory of it deals with very small
objects quantum mechanics two of them
don't play well together we don't
understand how gravity works on soar
quantum levels and if we see something
that differs from our expectation in
this picture of the black hole that can
help point us to one of many theories
that try to reconcile quantum mechanics
and general relativity it's also just
cool whether it's a pale blue dot or a
pristine portrait of Pluto seeing has
always offered us a new perspective on
the universe humans are very visual and
so we love having images and I think
having an actual picture of black hole
is gonna blow people's minds
I are like break continuity if I roll up
my sleeves and I'm gonna suck this one
over this is hard I was just watching
the Great British baking show last night
they were the same clothes two days in a
row
old bowed their yeah I feel like it's
wrong sorry yeah you can cut back like
that
you
you